[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo américa de france 24 y ya está
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
mar bienvenida feliz viernes ya nos
vamos a descansar hasta el próximo lunes
que voleó más cargados de más
información y vamos a empezar entonces
esta crónica con la organización mundial
de la salud que anunció un proyecto para
producir vacunas contra el coi 19 una
muy buena noticia es efectivamente una
muy buena noticia una buena noticia de
viernes precisamente no porque además no
se trata de cualquier vacuna sino
vacunas de arn mensajero las mismas que
usan la tecnología de facer o la de
moderna y que se han se ha visto que son
de las más efectivas contra el commit 19
y pues también que se prevé que sean las
vacunas que se usen la tecnología para
futuras enfermedades el primer centro
tecnológico impulsado por la o ms para
este tipo de vacunas está en sudáfrica y
se espera que ahora desde este centro se
pueda también transferir la tecnología y
el conocimiento a cinco países más
estamos hablando de egipto túnez nigeria
kenia senegal este anuncio además se
hizo en el marco de esta cumbre que hubo
entre la unión africana y los líderes de
la unión europea y el director de la
organización mundial de la salud explicó
pues las implicaciones que tiene este
anuncio
the benefits of design getting
más allá del hobby 19 creando una
plataforma para vacunas contra otras
enfermedades como la malaria la
tuberculosis e incluso el cáncer esta
plataforma no sólo será para sudáfrica
sino para todo el continente y todo el
mundo
esta iniciativa puede ser una solución a
la falta de vacunas en el continente
africano realmente una solución efectiva
una solución verdadera pues y eso es mi
análisis definitivamente un paso hacia
adelante en este sentido porque
claramente el sistema de donaciones no
funcionó no lo podíamos saber raúl que
gran sorpresa que los países del norte
global que se quedarán con todas las
vacunas y luego esas no llegarán al
continente africano repasemos las cifras
que venimos dando desde hace tiempo
también sólo el 25 por ciento de los
trabajadores de la salud en el
continente africano están vacunados
contra el cubit 19 y en cuanto a la
población general sólo el 10 por ciento
de la población ha recibido la pauta
completa lo que se intenta lograr con
este sistema de transferencia de
tecnología es que los países africanos
puedan producir vacunas propias es decir
que no estén sometidas a otras patentes
porque ese es el otro gran debate es la
gran batalla también ideológica
económica de salud que se está librando
alrededor de la propiedad intelectual de
estas vacunas y de hecho en esta misma
cumbre el presidente sudafricano con
declaraciones contundentes pues no sé
estuvo de comentarlo de nuevo
mari también
a camps con fans kampfer grupo llegó a
un punto incómodo la liberación de las
patentes los gobiernos que están
comprometidos con el acceso a las
vacunas y déjenme repetir el 9 repeat
cada mes de abril es serbios los
gobiernos que están realmente
comprometidos con que todo el mundo
tenga acceso a las vacunas deberían
asegurarse de que aprobamos la
liberación de las patentes with rooftop
chips way back' es en vez de esconderse
detrás de la propiedad intelectual y los
beneficios de los productores y de
profesión de let's of the origin le
echas raúl decía ramaphosa que era un
punto incómodo por qué pues porque
estaba diciendo eso frente a la unión
europea la unión europea todavía no se
ha pronunciado abiertamente a favor de
liberar las patentes sobre todo porque
hay algunos países dentro de la unión
como francia que sí lo apoyan pero otros
como alemania que se oponen de manera
contundente bayón tec una de las
productoras de la vacuna de país de
reunión te precisamente es alemana
entonces pues esa es uno de los motivos
por ejemplo por los cuales se están
oponiendo y todavía hay este debate en
él de la unión europea' mar también
entonces le quería preguntar
precisamente eso que le quería preguntar
a antes de la creación de ramaphosa qué
riesgos hay si no se liberan estas
patentes pues son varios más allá del
debate económico que existe hay un
factor y es que las farmacéuticas que
producen estas vacunas no siempre tienen
la capacidad de
solventar de responder a toda la demanda
que existe estamos hablando de que
queremos vacunar a todo el mundo contra
el co bit 19 un ejemplo muy claro de
esta batalla sobre las patentes es lo
que está sucediendo por ejemplo en
sudáfrica decíamos que allí hay un
centro impulsado por la organización
mundial de la salud que ha logrado
desarrollar una vacuna parecida a la de
moderna con tecnología de arn y
mensajero sin tener todo el acceso no
sería una vacuna digamos basada en la
información pública que existe de
moderna los ensayos clínicos van a
empezar en noviembre eso es una noticia
de la que todos deberíamos alegrarnos
pero la farmacéutica lo que ha hecho ha
sido aplicar para una patente contra él
por las vacunas contra 19 en este país y
muchos lo han visto como algo que podría
entorpecer el desarrollo de esta vacuna
propia sudafricana aunque la farmacia
asegura que no hay que sigue con su
compromiso firme pues de no hacer
cumplir las patentes mientras dure la
pandemia varias organizaciones entre
ellas médicos sin fronteras oxfam entre
otros pidieron precisamente pues a
moderna que retirara esta petición de la
patente y al contrario que incluso
ayudar a este centro sudafricano para
poder acelerar el proceso de fabricar
esta vacuna algo que también como
decíamos podría ser un paso hacia
adelante de
solucionar la desigualdad que existe
hablemos entonces de las posiciones que
han tomado the fighter by ontex sobre
este asunto y si les han tomado además
claro exacto eso es otra de la pues la
gran otra farmacéutica que está
implicada sobre todo en este en este
asunto y la verdad es que no tienen una
posición muy diferente a la de moderna
ayer por ejemplo estábamos explicando
que se anunció un producto nuevo un
sistema nuevo que se llama varios
containers bayot eines perdón con el
intento como de poder enviar estos
contenedores donde se puedan producir
vacunas como la de facer bayón tech sin
embargo es un proceso algo demorado y no
deja de ser una declaración de
intenciones de que esta farmacéutica
tampoco está dispuesta a compartir
libremente
de su vacuna la receta para que centros
que ya existen que no hace falta que
sean enviados a través del océano a
países del continente africano puedan
producir también la vacuna contra el
commit 19 mar pues gracias por toda la
información nos vemos el lunes con más
salud descanse este fin de semana
nosotros vamos entonces a pasar a
nuestra segunda invitada del día